Hello, my name is Abhinav and I'm going to talk about unlocking
link data in org mode.
So like a lot of you, I use Emacs on org mode for keeping a lot
of my data, personal information.
For example, if I'm trying to write journal entries,
it's most likely going to be an org mode file.
If I'm trying to save bookmarks or save links,
I again, they go into an org mode file.
Now, I was doing that earlier, but last year,
I think around last year, I started to use
these specialized applications.
So for example, if I'm trying to save bookmarks,
I'm going to use a bookmark manager.
I specifically was using drain drop for that.
What happened with that is that it allowed me to save bookmarks.
Let's say, when I'm on Go, I'm on a mobile phone.
I can just open my Android app and then save links to it.
I can also annotate and do other things
that you can do on bookmarks.
Similarly, for reading, let's say, papers and periods,
I would use that arrow for keeping notes about people.
I'll use a tool called Monika CRM.
Now, all these tools, the aim is to do one thing really well,
but they kind of work in their own silos.
And it's very hard to link data from one to another.
For example, if you have a journal application,
you can say things like, hey, today I met this person,
and then this person gave me this recipe, whatever.
But you know that the person information is still kept
in a different application and the recipe information
is still kept in a different application.
You have to do a lot of work to kind of make them come together.
So one thing that happened also last year
was that I started using org room a lot.
So org room is a little casting system
which allows you to have linked notes.
I'll not go too much into that detail,
but basically with org room, you can have
a lot of these text-based files that you make anyway,
and then keep them connected and have this knowledge base
that you can build around your information, your data.
While it's a good system, I still feel like it's not
very pro on providing very good amount of tools
for working with links.
I'll show two kind of things.
First is that I'll show how my current knowledge base
looks like, what kind of workflow I kind of use to save
let's say any information or how do I connect new notes.
The other is that because while this information base
is working out well for me, I still want all of my external
usages to be reflected back into this database of text files.
So if I'm browsing something, I still want that thing
to be saved in my org mode files.
With that, I'm browsing on Android or on browsing on Firefox
somewhere on a laptop.
So I'll show those two things here.
It's going to be a short talk, and then yeah, hope you like it.
So we'll start with this thing.
So this is a simple org room node.
It's a dummy node.
I've made a lot of dummy nodes here just to kind of show.
So maybe some of those information will be sparse,
but I hope I convey the meaning clearly.
So here, if you usually, if I just using plain org mode,
you just have this file, there's nothing else.
Now, if you are using org room,
you can do something called org room buffer toggle,
which will show you a few of those connected nodes.
Now, usually the connections are shown here.
They only show you backlinks.
So basically, any other node that has linked to this node
is going to be shown there.
But in my extension, you can see more things.
For example, here in this case, you can see,
first of all, we show both links.
So any link from this node to something else
will also be shown there, any link from that node
to something else will also be shown there.
So you can see that is one thing.
The other thing is that all these links are
categorized in type of nodes.
For example, when this node is specifically right now
is of kind book, tag is one identifier for it,
but there are other ways to identify a kind of node.
But this is connected to another node which is of a kind person.
So as you can see, the person A asked me to read this book.
So that link is shown there in a very rich format.
So you have more information about the link in this.
The other thing that you can see there
is that there are also links which are not existing right now,
but they could be possibly interesting for me.
So these are similar nodes.
So you can see the scores of similarity
and then other nodes like book on mathematics,
which are the another dummy node that I made for this demo.
Now, these are nodes which, again, I can just go in there
and I can see if maybe they make sense of,
I can just make those connections explicitly.
So let's try some other node here.
So let's say, so this is a node of a recipe.
It's a bomb by sandwich.
It's a recipe I've made.
Now, if you go here on the right, you can see,
there are some things on some person liking the sandwich.
There are some related nodes also, similar nodes,
which I am not linked.
Plus, there are some general entries.
Now, I use augroom daily to kind of write down general entries.
And then what I have to do is basically just write whatever I want
and then just make those links to this node.
So for doing that, I can see that there were two days
where I made bomb by sandwich and I had some observations
on it, which you know, I can see here, right, same.
So same for a person, let's say, if you go to person B,
you can see that, you know, this person has again linked to person A
and there's like some information around it.
Plus, there are some similar nodes there.
This works really well.
The similarity function works really well
if you're basically trying to go to, you know,
bookmarks that I've saved.
So, for example, here's bookmark that I saved,
which is Google at InterSpeed, 2033.
Now, this bookmark is a blog post from Google AI team.
Basically, it, you know, tells what research publications
they had in this conference.
Now, if you go to the similar nodes here,
you can see a very similar blog post from Google's team
for other conferences that they attended, right.
Now, this is really helpful for me, especially when I'm like
reading something later.
So I like to save a lot of links together.
And then when I'm deciding to read something,
I just open this and then see, you know,
however, everything is going to be what I'll say.
I have saved, should I read something else or not.
One interesting feature I was realizing,
I should try out is that, you know,
if I go to this node, which is person B,
you can see that while I'm linking this to person A,
I also have some context around that.
So I'm written, I've written specifically uncle of person A.
Now, if you have a semantic wiki,
you will have a typed link where you don't have a plain link.
You also have a type of the link.
So in this case, the type of the link could be, you know,
hey, it's like uncle Colin, whatever that link is.
But, you know, I don't want to like go into that as detail
and I don't want to like learn how to link things,
learn what kind of types I can make.
So I can just write things in plain text.
So I've written this in plain text.
What I can do now is I can just search for links like this.
For example, I can just do something like family members.
Now, this will show me all the links which have a context
which makes sense as family members.
So basically this is a semantic search on links
on the context of the links and then, you know,
it kind of gives me what I want here.
For example, here in this demo, I just had like one node,
one link which had this uncle relationship.
So that kind of works out.
Now, let's just try another search.
For example, let's say if I'm typing check before meeting.
So these are now again links where I have written something
where I kind of should do something before meeting someone.
So for example, the first one you can see,
there's a person called meeting person.
It's a demo node again.
And I've written one note about one connection here
is basically saying that, hey, you know,
read this link before you go to meet them, right?
So it's also been very helpful for me.
There are like a few patterns where I kind of feel
this works out well.
As I keep making more of the links
and keep writing more context around the link,
this kind of works out really helpful.
This becomes really helpful for me.
Okay, so the other few things, you know,
how do I like work with systems outside EMAX, right?
So the first thing is that, you know,
I haven't found anything that works really well
for saving bookmarks when I'm on my Android phone.
So I had to make new applications, application,
and it's called pile Android.
Now this application basically, you know,
let's me do whatever I was doing with Raindrop,
which was a bookmark manager.
So I can open links.
I can read stuff in Firefox on my browser,
on my Android phone.
And then I can say all of that in my org room database.
org room database here means the org room files that I have
because again, these are plain text files.
I can sync them through mobile phone
to my, you know, desktop and laptop and everything else.
So that's one place where I kind of, you know,
stop going to a new application.
I just basically ingest everything in my org room setup.
The other thing is that when I'm browsing on my laptop,
I still want to, you know,
collect all the data inside my org room system.
So here's something which I called org room site kick.
Now what you can do here is that,
let's say if you want to search for something,
so you can basically do a search normally,
which is going to do a web search.
But if you call org room SK, which is site kick,
it will do a search on all of your org room notes.
So now this search is basically using recall.
So recall kind of indexes all the plain text
and does a full text search for you.
But this is really helpful because when I'm searching
for something and I still want to know that,
hey, I have saved some of those links earlier.
So can I like, you know, see them back?
And then, you know, it's a very good way
to kind of not lose track of what you've already saved.
The other thing I can do is like I can also,
you know, again, since I have saved a project in my org room,
I can basically call again, site kick again
and I can see a note for that.
That note here specifically is tracking my tasks
for this project.
And other than task, you know, again,
I can see other things like similar notes.
I can see, you know, other links that are there.
So, yeah, so this, there's some optimizations to be done.
I think this, you know, the bookmark here
is not very intuitive.
I still want, I want this to be follow,
follow in the browser as I switch tabs.
But again, those things are something I'll work on.
Other optimizations include, you know,
the way I'm doing the search using ML
that needs a little bit of fine tuning
because every time I make a new link,
I have to like rerun the, you know,
re kind of build the features and everything else,
which I make it to be real time.
Yeah, so that concludes my talk.
Hope you enjoyed it.
Let me know if there are any questions.
Thank you.